okay so we know that you're now working
for bulk walker and geeks plus and all
that that's really great melee
so i said so condescendingly because
because that's not what i care about
i want to know what you were doing when
you were younger in japan what jobs are
you doing
want to we want to know about your
weaknesses
what is your path to getting to where
you are now we want the viewers
to recognize with your shonen
protagonist
we've told all of our back stories yeah
it's time for us to tell your
backstory okay so
i used to go to a lot of anime
conventions as you do
yes yeah and uh where am i going for
this
so you met your husband right yeah yeah
uh that's the thing
i forgot to tell the story or not to
tell the story i wanted to say like the
biggest tip is to envision
what position you want in the animus
industry and make
like steps to get there right the steps
i made for myself is one keep going to a
lot of anime conventions and make
friends yeah that work in like some
like in the industry yeah and
one of the people that i met at a
convention
happen to bring like japanese uh
rock bands right like yeah yeah japanese
rock bands to the u.s
anime conventions and then that person
like introduced me to a lot of people
that
we're in japan and the hardest thing for
a foreigner
or not foreigner for someone to get
there sorry
the hardest thing is to get into japan
with the visa
finding a job that will give you a visa
when you don't speak good japanese is
extremely difficult
so the first thing i did was get
a job that has no relation to anime to
get the
experience and then try to do
a consulting job that consults for anime
figure like type of companies oh okay
and then after that meet people
from that industry get the know-how from
them yeah and then
apply to the job that i have now
but uh gosh i'm like calculated
but it's yeah but at the end of the day
you know it's that age-old like it's not
what you know it's who you know yeah
it is like i i think i've heard like
similar stories with uh other friends
like nabi
who i like i had no idea how he knew so
many people in the industry i remember
asking him and
he was just like yeah just go to enough
events just talk to enough people
there's a lot of events here yeah
for me i'm like a nervous wreck like
yeah we can tell
do not be fooled by meline's nervousness
she is a killer all right
only you guys in the room so that's why
i'm like comfortable was like there's
more than that
yeah holy oh my god this would be soaked
yeah so like you have to meet people
network yeah and and like
a lot of people find that difficult in
the us and everything and like and
abroad because the only place i could
possibly think of is like conventions
and everything but in japan there are
like so many official events
that you can go to to meet people what
would you recommend then
like what should people look out for if
they wanted to just you know be in the
right place at the right time
um there's a lot of facebook groups
actually and a lot of these facebook
groups are for like the otaku community
and sometimes they have
industry people as surprise guests or
like just show up
yeah so go to those and you can meet
people or when there's like
they're kind of like panels industry
panels you can meet people at the
after party of these things okay yeah
i've i've like from experience i've had
people
one thing i know that doesn't work is to
just
go up to someone is to just go up to
someone
and be like hey i'm this person here's
my business card call me
oh yeah and i'm just like i don't know
what you do
what do you want to do with me oh like
i've had that so much they come to you
really like suave like yeah here's my
card
yeah i expect to hear from you you small
talk first though
yeah yeah well well like you know at
least explain like what is the purpose
of you coming up
yeah going up to people right like what
do you what what is the kind of
connection that you want it's not just
about like
i want to make a connection because i
want a connection yeah it's about
why do you want the connection what do
you want to do with the connection and
explain
why it'll be mutually beneficial right
don't just be like here's my business
card
if you if you know you know that they
would be in a beneficial position
you know sometimes i might just play
down be like oh yes what do you do yeah
they'll tell me like oh no way i'm in
the same industry
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's organic right
yeah all the time i'm realizing
all according to
it's because a lot of a lot of weaves
don't realize that one of the most
important skills you need to learn
when getting a job in any industry is
just social skills
no matter what you just gotta learn
social skills
i actually tutored like random people in
english in japan to develop social
skills
and like this this is this is this is
like like
should be inspiration for all of you if
this nervous wreck
can develop enough social skills to be
working in the industry and convince
[ __ ] japanese companies to form geeks
plus
there's hope for you as well okay
no amount of social anxiety is going to
stop you all right well the first time i
called with you i was like wow
why are she so [ __ ] nervous yeah on
the phone i think you're like oh it's
okay don't be nervous and i'm like oh
it's just it's winter it's really cold
because my voice is the worst thing to
say though right yeah
don't be nervous it's just going to get
the more nervous i think i was like why
are you so nervous
yeah you said that and yeah and then i
was like
okay i didn't know that that was like
yeah no no that's a no-no yeah because i
i i thought that i wanted to see what
kind of reaction meleen would give
i don't know why i just wanted to see
because i just got a vibe that you were
doing that in real life first
animation so that's why i didn't mind
and then you said the same thing you
were like oh you don't have to be so
awkward because i was like
because we were talking and then you
like well i i don't know if we can um
what the [ __ ] wrong
because i remember my first business
meeting with you as well and like
whenever
melin's negotiating it's like the most
hilarious thing i think i've ever seen
because
when we had the piece
like you're i feel like it's so obvious
if you don't like the deal that's
offered yeah
you're like it's like how how do i
say no without sounding like an [ __ ]
i know i know how she says this she says
oh oh
oh oh that's that's that that's that's
the
whenever you hear me lean saying that
it's you immediately like
oh it's not good isn't it no i was about
to say you can write a [ __ ]
dictionary on your [ __ ] o's and like
which which which tone you say it in
just communicate something completely
different
to us as well like when i'm like when
i'm texting you about like a business
deal and i'm like oh they came back with
this what do you think and
you legitimately come back with oh
i'm just like you pointed out i know
exactly what you mean
i remember the story i don't know if
i've told this i told you told you guys
about the time at promet
was a guy no no when i was at the
premiere of primarity x
there was a i was sitting in the studio
trigger seats because a friend
uh caramel yeah got me into the studio
trigger seeds and i was like well
it's [ __ ] cool yeah so i'm sitting on
the end of the studio trigger seats
right
chrome is about to stop yeah it's
obvious it's studio tricks all the seats
say reserve for studio trigger yeah yeah
so i'm sitting there and then this guy
in like a final fantasy
like cloud cosplay comes up to me and he
goes uh hey
uh do you work at trigger and i was like
uh no
these guys do he's like and then he goes
and then he's i say that to him and i
was like oh i made a mistake
because then he's like oh uh hello and
then i'm like oh my god
i'm over me hello bear in mind he's he's
full costume [ __ ]
giant sword yeah yeah he's like how do i
get a job in studio trigger to this
japanese man who can't speak a word of
english yeah and he's like
uh and he looks like hannibal you should
have just been like
not like this literally i was like bro i
don't think this is the right time yeah
yeah i
asked that to them they were visibly
confused i'm like bro i don't i don't
think this is
yeah he's like oh okay and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
what like with these kinds of people
what do they expect the answer to be
be like oh yes here's my business card
cause it's like really [ __ ] wonker
it's like you were the right guy who
asked
we were waiting for someone to be bold
enough to ask us
no [ __ ] off no that's not how you get a
job yeah
just like one of those moments i was
like oh no
that's second hand embarrassment right
yeah this is the biggest
l i've ever seen in my life yeah so so
advice right
at your next convention and you go you
see an industry guest
don't do that that's not how you get a
job he's in i couldn't believe it i mean
i don't think they're looking to hire
when they're at conventions
i don't know what person that's like the
hiring person wouldn't go to that event
anymore yeah yeah i think
i mean if i ran an anime company the
last place i would go
to hire people is the competitive
invention
yeah it just seems like the way to get
harder japanese companies it's just
first to be in japan right that's pretty
much in japan or like applied to
like us companies like crunchyroll yeah
yeah being like outright and so like
not even i mean that's a little
aggressive asking right like that that
kind of way just doesn't work it's like
you've got to like
insert he's like you weren't you weren't
even cosplaying as a trigger character
you know cosplay's [ __ ] clown turned
up full like ryoko
kill like oh as you can see i am a fan
can i have a job